and russia is also logging record case
loads of coven 19
more than 16 000 on tuesday alone
authorities there
are doing all they can however to avoid
another unpopular lockdown
they're also touting new russian-made
vaccines due to be rolled out soon
and as dw found out for many people
that's music to their ears
music is his drug nikolai makarov jokes
to him
it's essential the professional musician
directs an
amateur choir in moscow the group is
getting ready for an upcoming event
as if nothing has happened no second
wave of coronavirus during the pandemic
that has swept across russia and the
whole world
no one here wants to stop singing
despite the risk of infection
the risk here is no greater than the
risk of riding the subway or going to
the supermarket every day
of course we adhere to safety measures
keep our distance while sitting
constantly poor disinfectant all over
ourselves and so on
but ultimately belief and hope remain
if hope that all goes well
something the russians now could use as
their country has ranked number four
worldwide in new infection rates for
weeks
about 15 000 covet 19 cases are
registered each day in russia
but despite this dramatic situation
officials want to avoid another lockdown
like the one this spring
we've just extended the school vacation
to two weeks
all businesses are first being given the
recommendation
and later will be ordered to have their
employees work mostly from home
bars and restaurants must obey hygiene
measures in order to stay open
the city performs frequent checks on
individual restaurants and supermarkets
and imposes penalties if customers or
staff
don't wear masks for example
starting this week all guests must
register with an electronic code when
they visit bars
but many are not especially worried
about the risk of infection
we're all going to infect each other
anyway half the country has already
survived mild cases of coronavirus
myself included
i had coronavirus without symptoms and
i'm not afraid now
i think that sooner or later we'll all
get it
nikolai makarov's chorus say they get
tested for coronavirus regularly so that
they can attend as many rehearsals as
possible
if one singer tests positive for covet
19 he says
everyone would be notified immediately
[Music]
we can't live without music when we were
in quarantine for nearly half a year
this spring and couldn't sing together
we nearly sobbed in despair
[Music]
many of the choir singers want to get
vaccinated against coronavirus as soon
as possible
russia has just approved its second
vaccine against covet 19
despite international scientists grave
safety concerns
[Music]
and let's cross over now to dw's moscow
correspondent yuri rashetto yuri we just
heard in your report it mentioned those
two vaccines
that have been approved there in russia
do we know how
effective they are and what is the
outlook for distribution
well uh um this week uh
vladimir putin announced the approval of
the second new coronavirus vaccine even
though
neither of the russian vaccines have
passed the third phase of
rigorous safety trials required in the
us and europe
earlier in august putin reported the
first vaccination
even more one of his daughters has been
given the russian vaccine he said
this is surely called a pr effect it's
clear that the first to develop the
vaccine
is a winner in the eyes of the
establishment and ordinary people
for putin this might be his personal
breakthrough
sarah but the third taste phase of the
vaccine will only end in spring
only then we'll be able to see the
effectiveness of the russian vaccine
despite all announcements
talk with us a little bit about the
general situation because the number of
cases in russia is increasing
how well prepared are the medical
facilities there
well from a medical perspective russia
has of course learned a lot from the
first wave
it's not a third world country the basic
service works here
and it's mostly for free even meaning
really basic medical service
um of course the authorities have also
learned a lot how to avoid
uh bottlenecks in the hospitals but we
shouldn't forget about
the huge gap between the capital moscow
and the province
moscow is a thoroughly western european
city with pretty high medical standards
but moscow is russia's calling card in
the western bubble
the countryside is very different
pandemic is much more dangerous
there because many hospitals are poorly
equipped
there are also shortages of well-trained
stuff since
wages are extremely low and the best
doctors are
all here in moscow compared with other
nations i mean we we
saw those pictures for example of that
choir that was practicing there they
weren't wearing masks
um you know they they were singing um
are are the russians in general a bit
more relaxed about the pandemic and if
so why is that the case yuri
well until a week ago i would say people
in moscow were actually
very relaxed you could hardly see any
face masks
uh it's partly due to a long and tough
lockdown russian's experience in march
most moscow vice moscovites sat at home
for almost three months
and of course people felt relieved once
the restrictions were lifted
a memory of the lockdown is still
present though nobody wants to
it to happen again secondly sarah there
is also the russian mentality of the
so-called
a voice a voice means everything will be
fine somehow
thirdly the government's information
campaign plays also a role
it aims it aims to avoid a hard lockdown
as i showed in my report but
as i said it was like this a week ago
now the tide is turning in russia too
and we see
for example uh police officers officers
checking people at subway entrances for
wearing face masks so let's see
if another lockdown may be imposed here
in russia too
yuri rashedo in moscow thank you